Shawn O'Hara my compatriot from the NFL
Network yes is here I feel like I'm
saying this for the it is actually for
the fifth time you can catch Shawn on a
special eight and a half hour edition of
NFL gameday morning starting at 9 a.m.
Eastern Time on NFL Network a Super Bowl
champion from let me do that
man they it it's a it's it's a long time
ago Super Bowl heaven Wow no 11 years no
Super Bowl 42 right yeah yeah oh that's
now 11 Super Bowls ago good to see you
JB Smoove you're still 11 now how many
people think you were there for both
Giants I get that a lot yeah where's
your other ring you're wearing right now
you got the ring on yeah right now yeah
people ask where's your other one or you
know which one is which right a favorite
or you know which one you remember the
most yeah and the only one one just one
here so I'm gonna ask this question on
behalf of Chris Brockman no no I I don't
want to ask it anymore you don't think
we buried the hatchet we've moved on I'm
a growing 19 personal growth is that
right I'm putting the past I'm leaving
it in the paseo over to ask him if his
Super Bowl ring is on his holding hand
I'm holding on to the past and I mean
you're getting it it never fails
no not gonna hold on to things anymore
you know well you know that's call
that's called being clutch yeah yeah
that's okay I'm thinking about being
being the course he's not grab on to
something I'm on a rip it's okay to
decide it's okay to squeeze it's a bit
of clutch I might throw it down and then
I'm gonna forget about it so now Eagles
fans will remind everybody that they
obviously got Brady and Belichick last
year and for good reason
yeah are there any similarities between
this current Rams team and what they are
able to do and what you were able to do
to beat Brady and Belichick in a Super
Bowl for the first time well their
offense is definitely more explosive
than we were I think when you look at it
they're the most explosive offense in
the NFL and when you look at all of the
talent they have across the board they
prior more talented offensive team their
offensive line is phenomenal and they're
the only offensive line to start all
five guys the entire season they've
basically played
every snap so from that standpoint I
like this Rams team I think their
offense is they've got a lot of
continuity a lot of chemistry but the
one the the parallel that I see is their
ability to get to the quarterback
specifically inside with Aaron Donald we
saw Dante Fowler I mean everybody
everybody's focused on the no call by
the referee how about the fact that the
Saints had the ball in overtime and
Dante Fowler our beat Ryan RAM check
their right tackle who's probably one of
the best right tackles in all of
football beat him on a late spin move to
pressure Brees to throw the interception
in overtime that was a huge play and and
that's really how you win a football
game pressure at the end the Rams have
that ability like we did in the
Superbowl 42 we moved Justin Tuck inside
and he actually I mean he beat Russ hoax
teen their backup right guard he'd beat
him like a drum numerous times and then
we had OC and Strahan on the edges right
but that pressure think back to last
year's Super Bowl how did Philly win
Brady had the ball with time to go in a
time I mean I thought he was gonna march
down and they were gonna win the game
and then Brandon Graham lined up inside
not outside he was lined up inside with
the sack fourth fumble so that's really
what this games gonna come down to
yeah and Wolverine on Wolverine violence
oh hey I'm on yeah I'm Tom Brady I have
to have two points long I wonder sit
right there yeah yeah for the University
I'll do that so how do you thin blue it
it go yes yes exactly how do you see how
do you see it all playing out though
when it all comes down to it on Sunday
Oh what we've already I think Brockman
you can attest and JB's been here all
day what we've heard so far is you know
I think the Rams can absolutely do it
they've got this they got that they got
this they got that but I got but I can't
go against Brady that's what go against
him that's what we hear it every single
time so far so are you that camp I I I'm
in that camp yeah you don't bet against
Tom Brady you know you don't bet against
that team and what they can do now the
thing that's that's really been
interesting to me is I thought when the
Rams are down 13 to nothing in New
Orleans that was a wrap I thought it was
over with Gulf is coming over saying I
can't hear you he you know he and
McVeigh I mean they look like mimes you
know on a sideline they're just all hand
signals and I thought I'd say they're
done they're never gonna be able to
this golf it reminds me a lot of Eli you
know like you don't get much here you
know he's just very vanilla and he just
you know he just goes out and just balls
and and the way he was able to fight out
of that so that impressed me a lot that
that team was able to do that and rally
behind him in that dome and that place
is unbelievable I mean it rattles your
molars and they were able to overcome
all that so I think the the problem with
the Patriots is they just they don't
beat themselves so they make you earn
everything and I think the one of the
biggest reasons why the filly won last
year was they were aggressive they had
their foot on the gas the whole time
they went 4-2 early on they said look
we're not settle for a field goal the
fact they didn't kick it down there
early on a fourth down they went for the
touchdown that's how they won the game
the Rams gonna have that same mindset
Shawn O'Hara here on the Rich Eisen show
alongside with with JB Smoove so what
was your media day like what was Super
Bowl media day like at Super Bowl 42 we
already heard for Super Bowl 38 it was
not nearly as what it is now were you
please change will you podium worthy did
you get hold him yeah I don't know how I
don't do you remember the number of the
podium all right okay there were 14 back
then I think 14 yeah across the 40 you
remember that he doesn't we mixed it we
did it there were for sure I was 14
there's no way you remember that I
totally remember that across 742 we did
we did make we did do all that and
without by the way mixing it what he
means is a microphone at every podium
and to open it up and close it and
whatever we went to them I don't know
that of all the times that I do make fun
of of how important you make yourself
out to be yes those media sessions to
open the mics up and know what we're
taking and whatever crazy that was
impressive thank you rich but there's no
way you remember there was 14 podium and
for Super Bowl Sunday was an MVP winning
coach and six and six or seven and seven
on each side Wow for the postgame I did
not realize
I actually did do a little bit of work
paperwork yeah I'm like this show I
prepared I'm kidding but it makes it
makes sense that if I was the last
podium like that was it was kind of like
hey we got one extra one who should we
give it to let's go come on let's give
it to a lineman no okay but it was kind
of like one of those double-edged swords
cuz I was like wow that's kind of cool
all right I get have a podium but I mean
also as soon as the other my fellow
offers Lyman saw it that was it that
opened up the door to just because
you're not supposed to do all that stuff
well know what worth got one last night
so you tell me all the old linemen were
giving him grief
I think they appreciated I mean he
deserves to have you know I mean you
know what you didn't deserve to have one
no I mean I think it's just even though
I'm sure his guys are still giving him
just trying to think of my head sure
they're still giving him a heart so
obviously Eli got one and obviously
Coughlin got one TC stray straight when
OC would Galax lexico got one hey
Antonio Pierce yeah okay now we're now
now now now we're running out now we're
on Brandon Jacobs Reina Jacobs got one
now we run a nice team of course we're
gonna give the talkative yeah hold on a
second Mitchell a second telegenic
center of the New York Football Giants
from Rutgers gotta get you up there
definitely the record the rocker is over
the top gotta get the Rutgers but I
remember I'll never forget there was
there was somebody in there was a lady
there that was we're like a marry me
Manning sure oh yeah well like supposed
to Brady in ela I think both didn't she
didn't she [ __ ] she was from the from
the Telemundo right Brockman yes she on
TV azteca and she would show up in a
outfit McGowan in a bridal gown yeah so
he so so she wears the shirt says marry
me Manning and somehow somebody was able
to get one of those shirts yeah and our
left guard rich soy Bert who was 320
pounds we got him to put it on he got on
the boat when he got on the bus to go to
practice like the next day he was
standing in the aisle and Eli walked on
the bus he was wearing the shirt yeah
and I mean it was like a smedium
you know it looked like somebody had
poured him in
it's a great picture I got on my face
later all right JB Smoove I have them
figured you're a big fan of JB Smoove
Sean for sure I like the boots he's got
a clothing line so it's between him and
Amanda Strahan as far as women represent
Carl looks very nice it's a tuxedo shirt
denim with the denim denim tuxedo shirt
denim cord is in him so you did him
dinner I love it all right I've got
questions you didn't ask
oh you said you want me to read them out
read him out okay okay
I mean questions that JB Smoove could
not get to it last night's media night
James white you were gonna say this
you're so quiet and unassuming I almost
forget you're on the team is it true
that during a season you once
disappeared from the team for four weeks
to take your family on a Disney cruise
and no one on the Patriots notice the
captain to nobody even though he's the
captain
it's a captain he plays like a few
dollars a game that's so I thought you
who notices who note when he's not other
Belichick is Tom Tom Brady I mean think
about that play lat in the last game
when Brady thought about running for
them he thought oh I mean I'm gonna run
for the first down and open up he saw a
Dee Ford backed up and just pulls a
rabbit out of a hat but back shoulder at
the James white but when watching film
just the other day I'm so impressed with
James White's blitz pickup mm-hmm like
what everybody knows he's a great
receiver back til he brings all the you
know he can run the football you know
he's got great vision he is a really
good pass protect you know where you
learned how to pass protect like that on
a Disney cruise for weeks what else you
gonna do exactly under I mean there's
Mickey Mouse yes there's lilo there's
stitch and then there's blitz pickup yep
puto yeah and goofy I got a question do
they have roller coasters on Disney
cruise no come on be silly
there's no rides here's one for Robert
Woods you're from Gardena California and
played at USC so you're qualified to
answer this bigger event for LA football
the Rams coming to town or Jeff Fisher
leaving
sometimes go hard go hard go hard
sometimes look at and get you that one
great this I don't think anybody's ever
made this Super Bowl going seven and
nine there you go
we're six and ten right right Aqib Talib
you're a notoriously aggressive player
last time you were in a Super Bowl you
committed a vicious facemask penalty was
fined $26,000 my question is what
violent penalty are you looking to do
this time helmets a helmet horse collar
or the classic wet willy through the ear
hole oh please I hate that they just go
to flag on that I can see them doing the
wet willy that's a fifteen six thousand
dollar fine that explains why he's
stealing people's chains now how to make
up for it let's make up for it you can
ask us at both kickers oh yeah couldn't
get to the kickers last oh man it was
crazy
couldn't get to to pecker - heck no no
this is kicker all the polka Greg the
laser line Gostkowski okay and Greg's
Ison's foot what do you guys think of
the proposed overtime rule that would
call for a sudden-death where each
kicker gets to kick the other in the
groin until one gives up perfect
are you kidding me how would that work
can you walk me through what the real
how is that what would that look like JB
you go front you both stand in front of
each other where they do the corn twice
coin toss that okay the first one go on
in these so that sounds like a beavis
and butt-head sketch so you do you toss
the coin at all see who goes first
that's a crucial that you're putting
more on the coin toss than ever before
man and and you also can pass it you
know is there a recovery rageous thing
we can write this is great and last one
on that subject here you were a tails
never fails you call heads every time
what are you JB oh I like I like I like
tails
I'll go tails okay I'll go to you okay I
do amazingly both teams that won the
coin toss called heads for the Super
Bowl well and yeah both won the Rams
called heads and it came up tails and
that's how the the rant the Saints got
the ball last one Jared golf this is a
physical bit set up by saying that
apparently you didn't have the
opportunity to fully illustrate for
Jared exactly what he meant by your
question what does that mean you know
what I asked him very clearly I said
look you guys are the Rams you're doing
against a goat and Tom Brady oh he
thought what he thought I was talking
about like Tom Brady to go and I was I
was saying how does a ram beat a goat he
thought I was talk about the go Tom
Brady what's not my real goat I want a
ram be to go buckle you buck them now
that's only way they both have horns but
a ram is of course bigger than a Colt to
Ramsey to today
saute around and then one that's like
they both do this the same time and go
bucs
that's the only way a ramp to meet a
goat so I told him use that as a
metaphor for this game you buck the hell
out of that go
I like his Superman like this you say it
doesn't work you have the two kickers
come out and it's gonna be what if they
win the game yeah that's gonna be the
headline Rams buck Patriots or go go go
go go go okay
do you think that's gonna be the
headline when it's all said and done
Shawn O'Hara it's possible I mean who
knows the New York Post
[Music]
yeah
Rams you're right they they have horns I
mean everyone's are like we look at me
like wow look at the helmet I can't
believe that that like I just happened
like that's how they were made the horns
just growing the Holy Ghost we kind of
like antlers I don't think they're more
like like pointy they're like yeah
that's a good fight though but in the
hayseed in the I'd love to see the line
on so you think the Patriots win though
deep down Shawn are yes I think I think
they went another one which is
unbelievable
63 like I think that they'd be Tom Brady
starts edging into possibly the best
athlete ever ever any any small sport
still we talk about the goat but if you
if you heard those wins the goat was not
even on the field you know it's the
outer game could it with another
direction the Atlantic game could it
with erection but got teams who played
themselves into a loss but when you look
at that social game you know that was
the number one defense in the NFL and
and in the end of the game here they
were down with 14 points 10 points Grady
I'm back back drives shredded the number
one defense yeah to put them in position
to win that game they had to lead there
I still cannot believe it's they did not
give the ball to mark
I know you can he five years later I
know and I know and I know that what
that Belichick put in his jumbo doing 60
and what's so what and I know about that
when you see that defense you're
supposed to check into the passing play
or the passing place what's supposed to
be called but I mean come on that game
is over
the game is over I've never I have never
been in a situation because I was this
is the first one that I didn't have to
do a postgame show for and they were in
our NFL Network coverage so you know my
family's front my wife is from New
England and my that her entire side of
the family my brother-in-law
mother-in-law nephews were were in the
crowd and I we had our kids just our two
boys young boys in the stands so I
watched with everybody I'm in the stands
and I will never forget seeing all the
Patriots fans crying including my
children suddenly become related and all
the Seahawks fans who were beyond
elation begin to cry in one flip of a
switch I've never seen anything like in
any sport in baseball the World Series
and hoops never know never seen anything
like that before you know and so I still
will never believe that they ran they
did not it was by second only to the
Tyree helmet catch as far as Super Bowl
all moments like because what you still
need but you still needed to score a
touchdown that wasn't you know what I
mean like that wasn't yeah the end that
wasn't like me and curtain down yeah
over the finality of that right to go
from a 99.9 percent winning percentage
to a 0% or 28.1% winning percentage in
one snap of the ball and it wasn't even
just that they threw it but the play
that Malcolm Butler made on that he's
remarkable I mean it wasn't like a bad
throw by Russell right to me beat him to
the throw he beat him to throw basically
beat the wider seat up to it so I mean
you can run that play ten times in
practice and maybe he catches it once
yeah just because the bang bang of all
it takes is a split second maybe he gets
hit a second or half saying earlier and
now the ball ricochets I mean that
that play you just you can't timing up
any better I mean he drove he talked
about after he drove on the route soon
as soon as he saw that little you know
rubber out he drove on it
you throw the ball on the 1-yard line
you throw a fade route and guess what
it's incomplete
touchdown you win at the moment I know
about with the dangerous TRO yeah same
moment I thought about the miracle
somebody's he thought the game was over
he said yeah yeah that happens Oh what
happened
I know and again that would have
prevented a back-to-back championship
yes which we still haven't seen now
since the Patriots were the last to do
it in the first two two years of NFL
Network went back to back in our first
two Super Bowls that we ever covered the
one in Houston the one in Jacksonville
and Seattle they'd gone back-to-back
totally different legacy right there and
Tom Brady I mean he's Tom Brady's like
the Jordan the number of times that he
has denied legacies by winning one of
himself the number of times that a Carl
Malone was prevented for winning and the
number of times yiling bris printed for
winning the number of times that Hakeem
Olajuwon had to wait to win until Jordan
played baseball you know all of those
Brady Kurt one or an hour to denied him
a second ring he's denied the Seahawks
second ring no not-not-not you well you
denied yourself a second ring by not
playing for the Giants yeah I was more
it was more of them denying me yeah
[Laughter]
Shawn O'Hara will be part of the game
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience